poor booknotes jeanette conan last year
she sat down to discuss tuxedo park a
Wall Street tycoon and the secret Palace
of science that changed the course of
history it's about an hour
Genet Conant author of Tuxedo Park who
was Alfred Lee Loomis Albert Lee Loomis
was a tycoon who lived in Tuxedo Park in
the 20s and the 30s and he made a
fortune on Wall Street and he pursued
his hobby which was physics and he ended
up playing a very large role in world
war ii how did you get interested in
this story well in a sort of a curious
way I had a great uncle who was a
chemist who worked for Loomis in his
laboratory which was housed in a mansion
in Tuxedo Park for about 15 years and he
ended up writing a novel about his
experience there that was called
brainwaves and death and it was based on
the brainwave experiments that Loomis
was doing at the time in his tuxedo lab
and brainwaves of death was published in
1940 in January of 1940 just as a lot of
experiments and war research was being
done in this country and abroad and it
was a very scandalous happening in the
life of my grandfather who was then
president of Harvard and involved in a
lot of the war research and so it was a
family story that I had always heard
about and I decided to look into it and
that led me to Loomis
now there's a picture right here I
believed your grandfather that would be
a James B conan and his wife Patti and
that is when he was president of Harvard
in the 30s who's the fellow down here
that would be William Richards who was
my grandmother's brother and he was a
professor of chemistry at Princeton and
he's the author of the book though he
wrote the book under the pseudonym
Willard rich now how did you first
discover all this well he committed
suicide in 1940 who did bill Richards
the chemistry professor from Princeton
who wrote the novel and his brother also
committed suicide and it was a rather
famous event in my family's life that
these two
very brilliant brothers would commit
suicide their father had been a Nobel
Prize winning chemist at Harvard and
chairman of the department and my
grandfather had married the Nobel Prize
winners daughter and was a chemistry
professor and they went on to become
president University so bill Richards
suicide which correspondent with the
publication of his novel the novel was
published about a month after his
suicide was a terrible event in my
grandparents life because my grandmother
was devastated it was a tragedy the
circumstances surrounding his death were
very mysterious he'd been working for
Loomis for 15 years and this novel which
was a romantic laugh it was very thinly
veiled and somewhat scandalous about
Loomis's personal life and detailed all
the eccentric professors and experiments
had gone on in this private laboratory
and my grandfather I think took steps to
see that the novel was never published
it was too late and the novel was
published but it was very hushed up
anyway
this over the years gained great lore in
my family's life and every time somebody
died and we were in Mount Auburn
cemetery my father would take us to the
grave and go that one committed suicide
this way and that one committed suicide
that way and as a small child I was
always fascinated by these gruesome
events my grandparents never spoke of
them and you were not allowed to mention
them in their presence and I never lost
my fascination for that period now what
is the relationship of your either your
family or all of this to this man right
here Henry Stimson
yes Henry Simpsons no relation to my
family but Henry Stimson was Alfred
Loomis's first cousin and Alfred
Loomis's father had left the family in a
scandalous divorce oh they didn't quite
get divorced they were in the brink of
divorce but he'd left his mother when he
was a young boy and Henry Stimson was
the son of his mother's brother but he
was 20 years Alfred's senior and he
became Alfred Loomis's surrogate father
and he was in charge of his money he was
in charge of making all the decisions on
young Loomis's life and he was a
lifelong mentor and so during the war
year
when he was actually Secretary of War to
Roosevelt this was essentially Loomis's
mentor father figure closest friend and
so it meant that he had ready access to
the White House and it was one reason he
was so powerful during the war Henry
Stimson had been Secretary of State and
Secretary of War earlier and he was a
Republican yes it was a lifelong
Republican he'd been Secretary of State
twice under two administrations the
second one being Hoover's and he'd been
Secretary of War and he served in World
War one and he was 70 years old when he
entered the White House under Roosevelt
a Secretary of War so he was you know he
was a sort of revered figure he was very
stern stiffled Yankee I don't think he
ever could have won a popular election
in fact he ran for governor of New York
and lost resoundingly but he was really
a greatly admired and respected leader
and that is why Roosevelt went basically
to the opposition to draft him as
Secretary of War he brought in a very
famous war cabinet which was largely
republican many figures from wall street
george mcdee patterson many other
figures that was just a brilliant work
department by all accounts and they were
largely republican you've gone through
an enormous amount of stuff let me let's
kind of go back over a few of these
things first of all in your case where
were you born and raised well I was born
abroad but I was racing Cambridge and
Massachusetts and surrounded by many of
the scientists and figures that are in
the book I grew up with many of the
scientists giorgia Schakowsky who's a
famous Harvard chemist was a very close
family friend and he figures prominently
in the book as well he's more Loomis was
very close friends best friends with my
great uncle bill Richards who wrote the
novel and he and Richards were both
drafted by Loomis's young professors at
Princeton to come work as laboratory
hands in this deluxe private laboratory
in Tuxedo Park and they worked there as
young men and then later on the
friendship was still very close between
Loomis and mr. Kowski and he had
probably helped his Chesky no end in his
career and had given him money for
search and kiss Tchaikovsky came to him
later on with reports that he had heard
from other European scientists about war
work being done by the Germans
particularly in the area of building a
bomb uranium fission research and he
reported this to Loomis knowing that
Loomis was phenomenally well connected
not only in the scientific establishment
but politically and he wanted that
information passed at the top and Loomis
did in fact pass that information to
Vannevar Bush who passed it on to
Roosevelt and it's part of the reason
why uranium research moved as quickly as
it did in this country was this nexus of
scientists many of them who had worked
for Loomis at Tuxedo Park 10 years
earlier in the 30s at this laboratory
I've got just for the this is a very
expensive c-span graphic here that this
shows right here where Manhattan is
tuxedo parks how far away from Manor 40
miles northwest it was in those days
actually took just as long to get there
in those days as it does now there was a
much more efficient train then that ran
it took you 40 minutes and didn't stop
now you're this a slow boat that goes
and many stops and it was a 45-minute
drive so it was quite accessible it was
always a sort of gilded suburb people
listening why why should they care about
Alfred Lee Loomis well Alfred Lee Loomis
was really one of the top scientific
generals of World War two he was
appointed head of the radar division by
Vannevar Bush in 1940 because he had
been conducting secret radar research at
his laboratory in Tuxedo Park in 1939 at
at bush's request really we were not at
war yet and the government couldn't do
things overtly there was no
congressional funding for this research
because america was not involved in what
was then seen as the european conflict
and so much of this research was done by
universities and they were strapped for
cash in the 30s and Lumis was a private
financier who was willing to bankroll
research privately and Bush turned to
him and said look you know if you've got
the time the money the resources would
you do me a favor and look into
something called microwave radar that's
a very high powerful short wave radar
we think it's going to be quite
important in the next war and we ought
to be looking into and so Loomis
undertook a privately financed study of
microwave radar at his laboratory in
Tuxedo Park a year later in 1940 when
the office of scientific research and
development was founded by Roosevelt and
Bush was put in charge Bush immediately
tapped a number of men to be a
scientific generals my grandfather James
B Conant was his deputy essentially his
number two by the way who is Vannevar
Bush Vannevar Bush was a very famous
engineer at MIT and just a brilliant
scientist in his day he invented one of
the early computer systems he was a
mathematical genius and he was tapped by
Roosevelt to basically head up the
civilian based war effort a scientific
war effort it was a preparedness effort
that he spearheaded before America was
actually in the war but at that point we
knew everybody in government knew it was
probably inevitable that we would have
to fight but politically it was not
palatable so Roosevelt could not really
yet talk to the American public about
entering the war but we knew we had to
start becoming prepared and our military
was way behind our army our Navy our
radar we were not in the fight and we
were woefully behind your grandfather
James Conant was a president of Harvard
what years he was president Harvard
basically for 20 more than 20 years he
left in 45 to become High Commissioner
of Germany and what impact did he have
on the whole Manhattan Project the
building of the atomic bomb well he was
basically the he was the title was
administrator of the project but he was
the civilian liaison between Roosevelt
and Oppenheimer and he was basically ran
the Manhattan Project from an
administrative end who was Oppenheimer
Oppenheimer robert Oppenheimer was a
absolutely brilliant physicist from
Berkeley who was tapped basically by
groves and bush and Conant to run the
Manhattan Project it was built a bomb it
was gross general groves was in charge
of the
the effort to build a bomb during the
war back to either your grandfather why
would you ever know him oh very very
well he didn't die until I was 18 and we
were extremely close to him and I spent
many many summers his home which was a
vacation home in the mountains in New
Hampshire was our vacation home so we
spent all of our summers with him and in
in Cambridge we we spent a great deal of
time with him so I get the impression
that he was near Hanover near Dartmouth
yes well originally had been in Randolph
and then later as he retired he was
given a chair at Dartmouth and then he
moved to Hanover New Hampshire and that
was where the home was so where did you
find these photographs and these always
what kind of goodies did you find in
boxes in their grandfather's house well
it's funny is it as a teenager I guess
it's 17 I had been aware that my
grandfather was growing ill and I I knew
that it was my last chance to spend time
with him so I spent the summer my last
summer in high school before I went off
to college I spent the summer there
essentially working with them helping
out reading to my grandfather who at
that point couldn't read anymore and I
used to rummage because I was curious
down in the basement when they were
napping to see what I could find
and there were reams of old Diaries and
letters and correspondence so I had a
fairly good working knowledge of what
was available but of course it wasn't um
you weren't allowed to speak about it
when my grandparents were alive my
grandmother was devastated about the
suicide of her brothers and it was just
an unmentionable subject but I had taken
a pretty good inventory of many of this
old steamer trunks that they had that
they had used to go back and forth in
Europe and they were filled with letters
and photographs and long after their
death
young Harvard fellow named Jim
Hershberger was writing a biography of
my grandfather this was in the 80s and I
was a reporter then at Newsweek and my
father phoned me with asked if I would
be interviewed for the biography and I
said then don't give him the stuff on
this period because one day I think I'm
gonna get to it and so my father didn't
turn over everything and then after the
biography I believe it
great many of the papers were handed
over to Harvard and my grandfather my
father kept bill Richards papers that
had to do with this secret laboratory in
Tuxedo Park and the photographs and in
journals and things relating to it so I
knew I would get to it and so it was
sitting in Hanover in a steamer trunk
when I finally got around to it
when did you get around to it well about
five years ago I'd always intended to
but I had a career as a journalist and
it seemed a huge step to write about
physics in the war and I just kept
thinking well when I'm older I'll get to
it and then my father had some heart
problems and I realized that if I didn't
get to it quickly I would lose one of my
best sources so I started taping my
father interviewing him and getting him
to recall that period and the early war
years in 1939 1940 what was going on in
the household the research the pressures
of the scientific research that was
being done the the tremendous secrecy
that my grandfather and the other
scientists were operating under and and
then I also started collecting the
papers and that was about five years ago
and it took me about two years really to
to focus on Loomis as the subject in
part because many of my uncle's papers
were destroyed by my grandmother she
knew biographers were coming the
graduate students would be writing about
him and she was very embarrassed by the
personal tragedy there's
manic-depression
runs through the family and it's been
devastating and she did not want it
known and she burned a great number of
the letters and she tore passages out of
Diaries and the record was so spotty I
didn't think there was enough to sustain
a book on him but as I was doing the
research I became fascinated by the
laboratory where he had worked for 15
years in Tuxedo Park and I kept asking
people who is this guy Loomis and nobody
could tell me and that's when I thought
well there has to be a story here and
and that's how the book took shape
and as you found out there's a little
bit everything there's a picture here I
want you to tell me who this woman is
right here
well Loomis turned out not only to be a
brilliant Wall Street financier and and
physicists but he had quite a colorful
personal life because he'd married a
boston society lady and had done all the
right things and was really a sort of a
member of that sort of gilded mrs.
Astor's 400 set in New York he was a
blue blooded Wall Street type that very
wasn't the woman no and he ended up
taking up with his protegees very young
wife she was some 25 years his junior in
a very long secret affair that began in
the late 30s in Tuxedo Park and ran
right through the war years and they had
he built a separate house in Tuxedo Park
called the Glass House ironically it was
literally a glass house he was an
experiment in sort of inefficient
heating and and sort of in one of the
first solar houses and it had all glass
walls but it was very isolated and it
became a meeting place for him and his
secret lover and her name was Manette
Hobart and she was married to Garret
Hobart a young sort of amateur physicist
who was very wealthy who lived in Tuxedo
Park who was the grandson of a former
vice-president in the McKinley
administration named Garret Hobart
Garret Hobart the third to your
tournament and you have a photograph
here that excludes somebody in the
picture who is in this picture well this
is taken actually at the Hobart compound
in Maine and they think it's Ben it was
taken in a late 30s and that would be
when Manette was still married she had
two little boys then and Loomis was
married to his first wife and had three
small children
and they were carrying on this illicit
affair for years and at that time were
definitely involved and somebody cut
Garret Hobart out of the photograph he
would have been the oarsmen in the rear
there now people in my era might
remember another Loomis the son of
Alfred Lee Loomis Henry Loomis yes
West America yes yes
and president the corporation for public
broadcasting and many people will also
remember the older son Lee Loomis who
was like his father a fairly savvy Wall
Street guy and then he raced yachts like
his father and won the America's Cup
gold so he's quite well-known as well
one of the interesting things that I
found in your book is that one of your
sources that you quoted a lot was the
son Henry Loomis's first wife Polly yes
women have long memories well explain
something like that how why would Polly
Loomis who is no longer married to Henry
Lewis talk to you about this well first
of all part of the problem is virtually
everybody is dead so I you know as you
saw from the book it's its letters its
diary entries it's journals I mean thank
God people wrote fabulous correspondence
in those days and you're able to piece
together what was going on daily weekly
from those things and many of the
conversations were very important and
they they were done by letter that
people did not tend to speak on the
phone as much as they do now but most
people from that period are gone very
few men are alive Henry Loomis is the
only one of Lewis's three sons was still
alive and he's very ill where's he live
he lives in Florida and he has a sort of
degenerative brain ailment and so he's
not really able to recall clearly what
happened in the past what I did discover
however is that the women lived forever
and many many of the wives of these
scientists Georgia Schakowsky what's
it's his third wife I believe it was
still alive Elena Schakowsky several of
the scientists wives are alive and many
of the ex-wives are alive and Polly
Loomis was married to Henry for 40 years
or something they got married very young
in the middle of the war in their early
20s and she had a phenomenal memory she
was also quite a woman
she had flown great big airplanes that
she had ferried personnel back and forth
across the country and because she was a
pilot very good at navigation she and
Loomis immediately hit it off and she
was very very close to him in fact he
stayed close to a number of his sons
ex-wives who I think he actually
preferred to his
to some degree and his relationships
with his sons was fairly fraught but he
was very close to the wives and then the
ex-wives so she she was she recalled the
tuxedo lab very clearly she'd been there
many times and she was a wonderful
storyteller the one little nugget about
Henry Loomis you say that during World
War two he was responsible for from
Britain for preventing America from
bombing Kyoto it's a very odd fact but
it was a very close family and during
the war years young Henry had been
because he'd worked actually for his
father in Tuxedo Park during doing the
secret radar work and you have to
understand radar was a brand new concept
microwave radar wasn't known by anybody
it had to be mobilized very very quickly
and after Pearl Harbor he had been on a
naval ship in Pearl Harbor and he was
there in Hawaii
so he they quickly sent him to a radar
station in Hawaii where he began
training far more senior officers in
microwave radar which they put up very
quickly in Hawaii after Pearl Harbor to
bolster their defenses and anyway so he
he rose quite quickly in rank for a very
young man but at that time it would
throughout the warrior Stimson who was
his namesake his name was Henry Loomis
he was named after Henry Stimson his
Godfather he saw him quite often and on
a chance visit he had been in Kyoto
Henry and it studied Japanese art and
was a great fan of sort of the ancient
civilization and he had been going on
and on about this - Henry Loomis and
shortly after there was a meeting that
Henry Loomis attended with crow with
groves and Konan and others Oppenheimer
to discuss where the bomb sites for the
first bomb would be they there was
originally a feeling that it would be
industrial sites but one of the original
sites had always been Kyoto and Henry
Stimson piped up that this would not be
a good idea and he went on quoting Henry
his young Henry Loomis about the the
wonderful temples and artwork there and
the site was moved to Hiroshima now you
said you were born overseas what country
I was born in Seoul Korea
I actually live for several years in
Tokyo and what was that why were you
there what my father is a bit of an
inventor and an amateur scientist is as
well and he worked for years for Peter
Goldmark at CBS Labs and they were at
that time trying to invent the first
video tape machine and so he was back
and forth to Japan all the time doing
research and we were based there for
four years when did you come back
permanent to the United States I was a
teenager I came back in 74 where'd you
go to college I went to Bryn Mawr
where'd you study philosophy Greek
philosophy why the best department
actually I really studied it at
Haverford College which had a wonderful
philosophy department and a brilliant
faculty and I followed the faculty and
then what like most philosophy majors of
the day law school was the only way to
make a living and I thought I would go
to law school and a friend of mine said
it would be an awful pity and why didn't
I go to journalism school for a year all
the credits counted towards law at
Columbia it was a joint degree program
people like Benno Schmidt and Fred
friendly taught First Amendment at the
journalism school and it was a way to
ease into law school it was the one-year
masters and I thought that sounded dandy
so I applied to both the law school and
the journalism school and I was admitted
to the journalism school I think under
sort of some sort of program because
they thought I was going to be a lawyer
because I had no training in journalism
no interest in journalism I was famous
in my journalism classes the only person
with no prior experience you know you
had to list all of your jobs and I had
Greek philosophy major and that was it
and I was a source of quite a lot of
ridicule the year I was there and I fell
in love with journalism and I never
looked back
where did you work up until now well I
got tapped actually while I was at the
journalist school I was very lucky I got
hired by Newsweek partly I think because
of my travel background in my living
abroad and my languages and I went to
work for Newsweek and I stayed there for
seven years it was like getting a PhD in
journalism and I held every job while I
was there but because of my background
for several years
was the science technology reporter
because I'd grown up in Tokyo and with
scientists so I covered Apple and IBM
and you know gates and and Steve Jobs in
their infancy and had just a great run
so and in the front of the book you
dedicate this to two men for Steve and
John who are they
steve Kroft is a 60 minutes
correspondent he's my husband and John
is our eight-year-old son where'd you
meet Steve Chrome I was doing a very
critical piece on CBS which was rumored
to be on the verge of being bought it
well sold scuttled really by Tish and it
was a very low point in CBS's fortunes
and I you told my Larry - Larry Tish and
I was under armed guard as it were at
the affiliates convention in Los Angeles
because I was not supposed to speak to
anybody having to do with CBS and I was
surrounded by CBS PR people and I ran
into Steve there I was introduced to him
by a mutual friend and he was working on
a 60 minutes piece on one of my bosses
at the time Tina Brown who was at Vanity
Fair and I had worked for very fair for
some time at that point and he said well
I'd like to interview you and I said
well I'd love to interview you and that
was that what year was that that was oh
that's a trick question
that was 11 years ago what year was that
and you have an eight-year-old son John
and there was actually I remember seeing
books in the book stores with your with
your husband and your son a couple oh
yes a photographer snapped a picture of
the two of them and it was on the cover
of some father-and-son book back to
Alfred Lee Loomis how long did he live
oh he didn't he lived to be 78 he died
in the 70s in East Hampton where he
retired and where was he born he was
born in New York he was he was a really
a lifelong New Yorker and he had also
spent his summers in East Hampton as
Stimson had his family
in Huntington Long Island's they were
very much of a Long Island family and
Loomis was really considered himself as
Stimpson in the letters family letters
they always referred to him as sort of
Stimpson living a long time as Stimson's
do somebody says in a letter and they
were really in many ways a Long Island
family where did he go to school well he
went to a military academy and then off
to Andover and then in true Stimson
fashion you had to go to Yale and
Harvard Law it was a well beaten path by
Simpsons Henry Simpson had done the same
thing Andover Harvard Yale and then
Harvard Law School how did he then make
his money well because his father had
first separated from his mother and then
died when Alfred was in college he felt
the burden of having to support his
mother and younger sister and so I think
science had always been his first love
but he could not pursue it in those days
science was not certainly not a
profession that someone with no money
went into and it was not a lucrative
profession and did not hold promise for
any fortune so he he got his degree in
law and joined the very proper New York
firm of Stimson and Winthrop which was
Henry Simpsons very very much of a white
glove law firm and did very very well
very quickly after world he left to to
to enter the war World War one and after
World War one he went on to Wall Street
he could not abide going back into the
war into into a sort of slow Wall Street
firm give a photo here of him from World
War one he in many ways world war one
was a pivotal moment in his life because
he had really gotten on to a very proper
start in this white glove law for him
and he was following very much in Henry
Stimson's footsteps and he had been
molded by Henry Stimson and he was you
know a very nice proper corporate lawyer
and then World War one came and he
enlisted and he was because he was had
this incredible bent the sort of
engineering mechanical sort of inventing
bent and had
always played with mechanical devices
and was very gifted Henry Stimson saw to
it that he was steered to the Aberdeen
Proving Ground he he had an instinct
that this young fellow that he would
would thrive there and in fact he did
and he proved himself such an excellent
study in in sort of tanks and weapons
and defense systems that he was very
quickly made head of development and
research at the Aberdeen Proving Ground
and while he was there he he just proved
very gifted at advancing systems that
were already there he made several
advances in a recoilless shooting cannon
he he worked on funny at that point
Edison was a very old man and had all
kinds of notions about explosives and it
was his job to test many of Edison's
wilder notions some of which he said
almost got them killed money in the
process there was a no proper means at
that time of men of measuring the
velocity of shells fired from guns which
meant practically speaking you didn't
know how long it would take for them to
hit the target and there were various
systems for measuring that were very
bulky and commerson involved a lot of
equipment very slow and and not at all
practical in the field and he and
another scientist came up with a device
called at that time the Loomis
chronograph it was later called the
Aberdeen chronograph which was a very
sophisticated advanced system for
measuring the velocity of shells and
that was his first invention proper
invention I suppose and he did later get
a patent for that and I think that whet
his interest in science for life and he
would then return to it as soon as he
had the money so World War one he was
out of there in 1919 or so that's right
he was out of it in 1919 and his sister
had married a Yale classmate actually
the fellow was a year too younger his
sister Julia Loomis had married a very
very promising young banker named Landon
kay thorne Landon Ketchum thorne and he
was quite the salesman and by the time
Loomis came out of World War one thorn
was already known in in sort of the Wall
Street Journal and the newspaper says a
real up-and-comer a sharp ideal maker
and he
is considered to be one of the most
promising young security salesmen in
Wall Street and he had his eye on a firm
called bond Brighton company which was a
very sleepy firm most of its big clients
had sort of lost their money and it had
sort of lost its way and he and Loomis
partnered up
he talked Loomis into quitting the law
firm and joining in with him even though
Loomis was not at that point of banker
and they took over bond bright in a kind
of a bloodless coup and they took it
over and went right into public utility
financing and over the next 10 years
they would become the absolute leaders
in public utility financing on Wall
Street and would write over 15% of all
the securities issued billions of
dollars in deals and became phenomenally
wealthy and powerful in a very very
short run in the booming 20s how long
did he stay in that business he stayed
with Baum bright he steered Bob bright
to this tremendous success and then in
1929 he and thorne because they had been
underwriting most of the deals and were
intimately acquainted with the market
fluctuations as they made these public
offerings on these enormous super power
companies they felt that the market was
out of control their last offering it
was a united corporation enormous
superpower it was done with Morgan it
was one of the biggest deals of its day
and it went for a huge price much higher
than they had thought it deserved
and they felt at that point that the
market was out of control they very
quietly began pulling out of the market
and putting all their holdings in cash
and when Black Thursday hit 1929 they
were sitting on a mountain of cash and
they proceeded to do very well then in
the subsequent years along with there
were other finance years Bernie Baruch
and a few others who profited in the
Depression years when others really lost
everything and Loomis is estimated to
have made about 50 million dollars
between 29 and 34 and really I think
once he had that fortune he wanted to
return to his old Bluff he'd been doing
science
all along sort of in the backyard
laboratory and then in a larger one in
Tuxedo Park and he quit Wall Street he
resigned from every board and in 1934 at
the age of 47 he became a physicist
full-time hey Jeff do you say 47 he was
47 there's a picture of tower house
where is this that was the mansion that
he bought in Tuxedo Park he actually
bought it in 1926 it was about a mile
from his family home which was another
stately mansion where he lived with his
wife and kids and tower house was a
crumbling old mansion and he gutted it
and turned it into a state-of-the-art
deluxe laboratory he put the most
expensive equipment in the world in that
laboratory that was equipment that at
the time universities could not afford
he bought three short clocks they were
very famous astronomical clocks the most
exact locks in the world of that Big Ben
isn't a short clock they were fabulously
expensive
he bought no less than three for his
laboratory and over the years in the
late 20s and throughout the 30s while he
worked on Wall Street during the day he
would go back to Tuxedo Park on weekends
and do experiments in physics with this
fabulous equipment in this was basically
a private scientific playground that he
had built for himself and during this
period he would send first-class tickets
and invitations to all of the most
famous European scientists basically the
men he wanted sort of to play with and
study with he met them on trips to
Europe they had made with a very famous
American physicist named Robert Wood who
he had met at Aberdeen and they had sort
of teamed up he was financing would
studies and would was teaching him
physics and would was a really a
brilliant eccentric figure very
colourful very well known in Europe very
highly regarded and they would offer
these invitations to Marconi Heisenberg
Einstein and they would say here's
first-class tickets we'll pick you up in
a Rolls you will come to this fabulous
mansion and you will you will be hosted
at a fabulous scientific conference and
Black Tie dinners every night and
Averell Harriman will drop by for drinks
and then we will do physics during the
day in the state
of the art laboratory and the Europeans
understood this concept because it was
it was very common in Europe for famous
scientists to have laboratories in
mansions next to their manor houses a
Darwin had had one very famous British
physicist named Lord Raliegh had had one
Thomas Merton another famous physicist
had a normos laboratory built in a
mansion right across the river from his
estate so this was a concept that was
very familiar to Europeans it's also
very common in France and they would
come they would accept this imitation
and one by one they came to Tuxedo Park
throughout the 30s these are the
Depression years American universities
have no money and they would be sort of
on a lecture tour so they would accept
this first-class steamer ticket they
would come to Tuxedo Park and give a
talk 40 or 50 famous scientists from
around America would convene Tuxedo Park
and then they would go on their lecture
circuit but they had been well financed
already by Loomis
of course Loomis gained quite a
worldwide reputation in in in a decade
or so that he did this I mean he knew
everybody in the world of physics and
biology chemistry how many homes are
there in Tuxedo Park well it's actually
quite a small area but you mean of these
mansions I mean when you talk about
Tuxedo Park what are we talking about in
terms of about six thousand acres it's
quite a small area but in the turn of
the century when it was first settled by
this tobacco heir Pierre Lorillard it
was set up to be the most elegant resort
sort of hunting and fishing community
and it was first dubbed the short season
place between Newport in New York you
were supposed to go there in the fall
and shoot and have this fabulous hunting
mansion and it then became a gilded
suburb by the time Loomis arrived in the
1920s what's it like now well he's
enormous mansions were built you know
60,000 square feet you know 40 bedrooms
they had to have 25 servants to run them
and it was Impractical by any measure it
was virtually decimated by the
crash it was really it was Morgan's it
was Vanderbilt some asters galettes it
was really New York banking money and
railroad money and it was devastated by
the crash of 1929 many many houses were
scuttled burned because people couldn't
pay the taxes or they they lay empty for
so many years that they were
uninhabitable and later torn down during
those years he was married to Ellen
Farnsworth and there's a picture of her
right here that with his society wife
she was the prettiest debutante of her
year in Boston what was happening during
those years what was his relationship to
her well you know she was a classic
product of her day in Boston actually
very similar to my own grandmother they
were from very learnand families they
were well-off and their brothers went to
Harvard and they were schooled at home
and they were educated in Greek and
Latin they read French and German and
Italian
they knew opera and they couldn't do
anything they couldn't boil water they
were utterly impractical creatures and
and quite thwarted because they were
very bright and it tended to produce
singularly neurotic women and Ellen
Farnsworth was no exception she she was
really far better educated than most
women of her day but utterly unable to
run a household she couldn't function at
all she always had to have five Irish
maids around her to dress her to to
bring her tea and she spent many many
afternoons prone in her bedroom taking
various sort of drafts to calm her
nerves and she was quite a handful and a
very old-fashioned woman considering
that she married a very energetic sore
forward-looking man who would later
become a scientist so they were
ill-suited did she have any idea that he
was having this ongoing affair with
Manette that is very difficult to say
when you think of how small a community
it was and how often they saw each other
this young couple the Hobart's had a
house right near their son Tuxedo Park
she had pretty much taken he had taken
Hobart
as the director of his laboratory Hobart
didn't mean to work he was very wealthy
it was sort of a hobby for him an
occupation and he was interested in
science as Loomis was and he ran the
laboratory and and and Ellen Farnsworth
Loomis pretty much adopted Hobart's
young wife as a daughter almost so they
they would have had dinner several times
a week they vacationed together they
took cruises together they were very
very close
so for how long did the affair go on
well nobody knows exactly when it began
but it probably had begun by 38 or 39
and they it was in secret you certainly
that the Alfred Loomis had a signalling
device of mirrors or something to let
her know that it was time for the yes
get-together
their houses were a cross tuxedo lake
from one another tower house was on a
very high hill and it looked down right
across tuxedo Lake to the shoreline in
the Hobart house was right on the cliffs
and he developed a system of mirrors
where they could flash each other to
indicate that they might want to meet at
the Glass House the separate third
structure that he built as a guesthouse
and it became pretty much their private
hideaway most people believe that mrs.
Loomis must have known she hated the
Glass House and Alfred would not allow
any of the household staff cleaning
staff to enter the house or his wife or
his well she wanted no part of it but it
was off-limits to everybody except a few
of the tower house scientists visiting
guests and I think that it's it's it's
very likely that mrs. Loomis knew what
was going on in those days of course it
wasn't that uncommon and you didn't say
anything in 1945 April the 4th near the
date that FDR died here is the wedding
picture yeah including this whatever
that what do you call those some buff
would be a fur muff in fact I saw the
actual suit the Hobart family still has
it it's a size two bond whant and Teller
black suit with white rabbit cuffs and
collar it's quite a an item and where is
this tape the shotgun wedding and Carson
City Nevada he married Manette he
shocked everybody by marrying Manette
the day of his divorce later the same
day of his divorce in 1945 he's 57 she's
36 that's right
did they ever have children they did not
she she had two very small children her
children were much younger Loomis's
children by then were were out of
college and in fact they had all just
returned from the war all three of them
but she named one of her children she
had two sons two small boys at that
point they would have been about six and
seven and her youngest son was named
Alfred Lee Hobart in honor of his
beloved Godfather and that was always a
source of some scandal but what happened
in New York society after they married
it was considered very shocking I
actually interviewed a number of people
that still worry sort of younger members
of Bob Brighton company and Wall Street
firms that remembered the scandal
surrounding the divorce and wedding and
it was just not done you did not divorce
your sickly Society wife you certainly
did not try to put her in a mental
institution to get her out of the way
which is what Lumis at one point
attempted to do with his wife when he
was seeing Manette and it was also seen
a bit as stealing the wife from his very
proper protege his best friend and also
because they had been in his employ
there was some feeling that he had been
marrying an employee she had worked for
the tower house as well in part time as
the secretary during the war years and
and that was just not done it was so
scandalous at the time that many of his
lifelong friends Henry Stimson spears
the heads of of Winthrop Stimson and
Putnam at that point a very very
powerful law firm literally snubbed him
people he'd known his whole life
wouldn't speak to him and turn their
backs on him and he was really a social
pariah for some years
is there anything particularly
interesting for people who endorsed your
book on the back Kurt Vonnegut Timothy
Ferriss Stephen Ambrose and Ken Auletta
are they friends did you ask them to do
that or was that the public
Kurt Vonnegut is a friend and because
he's written so brilliantly about World
War two and in fact was at Dresden he
was somebody I spoke about spoke to
quite often when I was writing the book
he has a house in Sagaponack and I see
him very often in Long Island during the
summer and he was tremendously
supportive so I sent him the book I knew
it would be of interest to him Ken
Auletta is a great friend and because he
writes about great corporate tycoons and
figures for the new yorker we thought it
would be appropriate Tim Ferriss and
Ambrose are two of the authors that my
editor Alice Mayhew at Simon & Schuster
has nurtured a law and so that was her
choice who's in this picture right here
that's a very famous photograph that was
taken in Berkeley and that is when the
group of physicists were meeting at
Lawrence and Loomis's request to discuss
the financing of the big atom smasher
Alfred Loomis all the way to the right
your grandfather in the middle James
Conant James Conant is the one with his
hands up in the middle Loomis is in the
far right like then there's a van of our
bushes in the middle there under the
blackboard the glasses Ernest Lawrence
is on the way on the far left I believe
you have Karl Compton was sitting right
next to Loomis and Arthur Compton is
next to Lawrence and it was I think
taken by John Koch Rob when you hear the
name Ernest Lawrence is that the
Lawrence Livermore Laboratory it is
located where that's located in
California and and and Ernest Lawrence
was a Berkeley physicist and he happened
to visit tower house in 1936 he was just
one of the many physicists who came for
a conference there he was already in
1936 a a formidable figure at 1930 he
had invented the cyclotron the first
atom smasher and he was you know
achieved international acclaim by then
what's this picture that is a picture of
I think the 60 inch cyclotron which was
an even larger atom smasher which he
then built at Berkeley and he was
he had raised money for something called
the rad lab at the radiation laboratory
at Berkeley it was a very very famous
physics laboratory where he was
experimenting with with high accelerated
particle beams and very high voltage
generators which is essentially what the
cyclotron was and Loomis and Lawrence
took an immediate liking to each other
in 1936 they literally became best
friends over that weekend and by the end
of the weekend Loomis was completely on
board in terms of wanting to back
Lawrence's research Lawrence this is the
30s it was in constant need of money and
here he was a brilliant physicist he was
eager to get on with building these
machines and he spent more than half of
his time fundraising traveling the
country trying to get corporate bigwigs
and Rockefellers and people like that to
give him money and scrounging for parts
and supplies and and and and and and any
kind of funding he could get to pay for
the kind of physicists he wanted to have
work for him at this giant laboratory
Research Laboratory he was putting
together at Berkeley what is the ran who
invented it what impact did it have on
the war well Lauren stands for
long-range navigation device and it was
everything that was done during the war
by Alfred Loomis was really done in the
field of microwave research very
powerful microwave transmitters but
there was one exception of when the
British came over was something called a
cavity magnetron this very powerful
generator that would would allow them to
have microwave radar systems for the
first time and they created the MIT
radiation laboratory
the MIT rad lab to build these powerful
microwave systems that were based on the
British cavity magnetron everything was
done together with the British and the
idea essentially the the basis for the
systems came from the British they
brought with them all of their years of
research that they had done in the 1930s
and their experience was called the tzur
admission who's this crowd right here
that is in fact in front of the Glass
House the secret hideaway house in
Tuxedo Park and that is the Tizard
mission
in the fall of 1940 which ones taffy
Bowen taffy Bo and is this happy looking
fellow right next to Ernest Lawrence and
that's Loomis on the far right that's
the MIT radiation specialist egg Bowles
is next to taffy bone and he was British
taffy Bowen was a was a brilliant radar
pioneer and he was British and he had
helped build the chain home system which
had guarded London during the Blitz and
he and Co Croft and a number of other
top British radar specialists at Co
Croft was a physicist in fact were
tapped by Henry Tizard and charge really
by Winston Churchill to go to America
with all of Britain's top military
secrets and this very precious invention
the cavity magnetron which held the
future for very powerful new radar
devices to smuggle them across the ocean
to America and see if they could not
convince the Americans in exchange for
all these military secrets and
technology to aid Britain by building
these devices Britain had done
tremendous work but they were under
siege from Germany they didn't have the
men they didn't have the materials and I
didn't have the money to develop these
scientific ideas any further America was
not in the war we could not really
publicly support them but we could
privately continue the research that
they had started and that is what
Churchill was hoping for it would later
develop and in flourish under something
called the lend-lease act and that gets
very complicated but this was basically
a backdoor way of getting American
support and Lumis personally invited
them to Tuxedo Park they unveiled this
cavity magnetron in Tuxedo Park
Lumis privately financed the early
research and radar and then Roosevelt
gave him a very large grant and they
started this private laboratory in MIT
to actually build most of the radar
systems that were put on virtually every
airplane and submarine during the war
during this time Loomis developed the
notion for something called Lauren
whether or not it was based on ideas
that he may have gleaned from the
British nobody knows the British had a
rudimentary system called GE II that
bore many similarities to what Lauren
would later become but GE was not among
the ideas that was disclosed the
Americans so it is not clear whether he
extrapolated some of this information
from the British and then made the
necessary leaps to what this system
should look like whether he came out of
came up with it spontaneously which is
not incredible to believe because many
radar systems and devices that people
had most of the knowledge and it was
coming up popping up similar devices all
over the place it was sort of right at
them at the bursting point anyway he
developed this notion for a long-range
radar system a kind of a grid system
where you could track vessels at great
distances and it became one of the most
important navigational devices during
the war and is still used today by the
way who went on then to found the RAND
Corporation
well Loomis worked with a number of
sleev brilliant scientists and
administrators and lawyers in putting
together this giant laboratory and
running it all during the war it was a
massive operation
it's a 2,000 people at one time at its
height and and and millions and millions
and millions of dollars in congressional
funding and they issued hundreds of
thousands of contracts I mean the number
of devices commercial devices that came
out of that laboratory and these were
you know contracts that they were
writing by the hour by the month and
they needed very sophisticated lawyers
and business and men to run it one of
the lawyers that he hired was a San
Francisco attorney named Rowan Gaither
who became Ernest Lawrence's closest
friend as well and Gaither founded the
RAND Corporation and asked Loomis to
help be a founding member of it and he
and Gaither
laid the groundwork for what became the
RAND Corporation this is off topic a
little bit but who but who bought Hilton
Head South Carolina at the height of his
Wall Street fortunes he and Landon thorn
this was B at 1930 we're live
very large they went through a period of
sort of well we're familiar with it from
the 80s when tycoons start spending
their money and they bought a they
bought an America's Cup yacht which they
raced in 1930 and that was only sort of
Vanderbilts and asters did that in those
days syndicates of millionaires was
unheard of for to individual tycoons to
take on such a large expense and the
following year in 1931 they decided to
buy Hilton Head Island well twenty
thousand acres plus a huge tract of land
it was then largely uninhabited island
there was no bridge that was only
reachable by boat and they bought it as
a private hunting and fishing reserve
and they had it for Oh nearly twenty
years about at a time but I want to ask
you about your grandfather James Conant
former president of Harvard for twenty
two three years or whatever in the end
even though he's involved in the
Manhattan Project did he want to dropped
a bomb well I do think he wanted to drop
the bomb I mean want to is it is a
difficult term but at that moment if the
prevailing wisdom was we were world we
were war worried weary as a nation and I
think that that the feeling man was that
you had to do something to shock the
Japanese into backing down I think they
did want to drop the bomb the first one
anyway however after the war my
grandfather was among the scientists
that became very remorseful and with
some of the other Los Alamos scientists
he found the Society for the Prevention
of you know nuclear proliferation Loomis
and Lawrence went the other way
they never suffered from any remorse
about their role in the development of
the bomb and they proceeded to push for
the development of the h-bomb which my
grandfather was adamantly opposed to so
they split very much in the 50s when did
they shut Tuxedo Park down he shuddered
Tuxedo Park in 40 when he when he went
off to start the MIT radiation
laboratory and he never really properly
returned and then he sold it in the late
40s when he died he died in 78 of what
he had a stroke and dropped dead
literally on the spot they found him on
the floor
his wife Manette she lived for a long
time thereafter and she actually Loomis
had asked an old protege of his from
Tuxedo Park one of the scientists who
would work there for him if he would
look after Manette after he died and she
then married him a year after Loomis's
death what was his name
I was afraid you would ask me that and I
can't think of his name I think for a
minute this book for you what kind of an
experience was it you know it basically
had endless pleasures because the
character of Tuxedo Park that community
was great fun as a backdrop a very close
third waspy sort of gilded environment
and the most unlikely place for somebody
to start a secret physics laboratory
where he would invite the brilliant
scientists of Europe and then of course
all of the fleeing Jewish scientists who
came in much to the horror of his
neighbors as they came to Tuxedo Park to
visit Alfred Loomis so you had this
wonderful locale and then this this very
grand complicated eccentric character
and so it was a great sprawling tale our
guest has been Janet Conan this is what
the book looks like Tuxedo Park all
about Alfred Lee Loomis and we thank you
very much for joining us my pleasure
Tuxedo Park a Wall Street tycoon and the
secret Palace of science that changed
the course of history is published by
Simon & Schuster on the web at Simon
Says dot-com
next week on encore booknotes Hampton
sides author of ghost soldiers the